والى باخمود التي تحولت المعركه فيها
لمعركه كسر عظم بين القوات الاوكرانيه
ونظرتها الروسيه التي حاولت وفشلت على ما
يبدو في تحقيق اختراق كبير في المدينه
لتسلم المهمه لمن لمرتزقه مجموعه بدات
المجموعه المواليه للكرام لن تحاصر القوات
الاوكرانيه وحققت اختراقا باتجاه قلب
المدينه وفقا ما نقل معهد دراسات الحرب عن
مصادر روسيه ومدونين عسكريين موالينا
لموسكو زعم احد المدونين الروس ان تجمعات
القوات الاوكرانيه في بخموت باتت متوقعه
فيما اكد ممول مجموعه فاجنر جوزين انا
قوته حصرا هي التي حققت هذه المكاسب دون
اي مسانده من القوات الروسيه التي هاجم
قيادتها بشده القى بريجوزين باللوم على
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لعدم قدرتها على
تحقيق مكاسب في محمود وقال في مقابله مع
وسائل اعلام روسيه ان قوته لم تتقدم في
المدينه لان الجيش الروسي لم يقم بتطهير
المباني امر اثار رداد فعل سلبيا لدى
المسؤولين الروس وفق معهد دراسات الحرب
الامريكي خصوصا بعد انتشار مقطع فيديو
بالقرب من بخموت لمرتزقه فاجنر وهم يشتمون
رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الروسيه فاليري جرسيموفا ويشكونا من نقص
الذخيره في معاركهم
قبل ايام ظهر مؤسس في خطي الجبهه في محمود
كما نرى في هذا الفيديو وهو يراقب جثث
عناصره مكدسه بالاكياس قال ان الجميع يريد
ان يعرف متى سنسيطر على مخنوق الا ان كل
منزل اصبح حصدا واضعف
رجالنا احيانا لاكثر من يوم كامل للسيطره
على منزل واحد وفي بعض الاحيان تدور
المعارك لاسابيع على منزل واحد وكل عشره
امتار هناك خط دفاعي اوكراني
اختراق الدفاع يعني اختراق الدفاعي منزل
واحد ثم عليك ان تكسر دفاع المنزل التالي
اليس كذلك هو ليس مجرد خط الدفاع واحد كم
عدد خطوط الدفاع الموجوده اذا قلنا 500
فسيكون ذلك دقيقا اليس كذلك